i got to bring this up because i got
roasted last episode for not knowing
what an accountant was
oh i got roasted idiot so it's not
actually
i found out it's not an actual
accountant that's a word for a sex
worker
oh an idiot oh yeah what i didn't know
that
what actually no so we both
yeah people are roasting us man they're
like so cute they don't know what that
word means
but that's what it means and i guess all
right [ __ ] and you guys don't know what
a red tree black tree is so [ __ ] off
like yeah
there are things you don't know get
versed on comp's eye [ __ ] yeah you
don't [ __ ]
okay you get all [ __ ] oh that's so
cute you don't know what accounting is
[ __ ]
tell us about your options strategy and
and your [ __ ] short selling
strategies and trading oh that's right
you can't you don't know [ __ ] about it
sorry we're just always chilling with
our wall street bros on
[ __ ] 10d lane and accounting to us
means getting the bag
yeah what's the best brand of attendees
huh what's the best brand yeah you don't
[ __ ] know you don't know
if you haven't eaten them yeah you
haven't eaten them like we have you
don't analyze them like we have
they're gonna be condescending about us
not knowing this you know this new term
and we also got roasted because we
didn't know that bimbo tick tock was
was uh uh you know a thriving genre
and also the fact that we didn't know
bimbo was like a term that was like
reclaimed
as like uh as like a powerful um
what you're saying is we have crossover
with the bimbo community
yes i guess so i think we're bimbos
shadow bimbo community shout out bimbo
accountant community
can we so luke prepared luke and kyle
prepared some
bimbo tick tocks to educate us yeah so i
thought we could take a look at a couple
of those
i dig that homemade baby gravy
hi i'm an accountant and um i needed to
make a bodily fluid that i could not
produce today
uh so i fabricated a way on how to make
it
as realistic as possible you're going to
need something to mix in
personal lubricant conditioner some
water and some sort of item to stir it
all right so i put this is exactly how
it's made as well
the lube in there and then like one
is she making squirts yeah maybe gravy
in there and what you're going to do oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh you're going
to
mix it up and it already is like
immediately
starting to look um
like i don't know why that water that
you're gonna add is going to be that
made me want to vomit i don't know why
say goodbye to ads on this video on this
episode
oh wow holy [ __ ] have fun
have fun have fun okay so that was an
accountant tick tock not a not a bimbo
one are you
that's that's a i mean based on that
that's kind of like
i don't know that's like practical
effects yeah that's true
yeah that's a good point yeah but if
anything
you guys should start to reclaim some
other terms hi practical
practical effects artists here lady
whale shark i'm going to teach you a
little bit how to make baby gravy
um yeah
no whatever i mean it was impressive no
but i've heard that
that's like a thing in porn already like
they a lot of the
money shots are like they're fake
oh okay because
more often than not it's like really
it's hard
it's hard to get a perfect money shot so
that's why
i was good some porn star was tweeting
about that like years ago
it was basically like oh yeah the dick
is either like
like framed out you know or or like it
like
you know they'll pour it on and then the
dick comes in and
you know dude's got a little bit in his
hand and he's like oh
i'm picturing one of those tick tocks of
the dudes getting blasted by like
condiments or friends
[Laughter]
it's a money shot where they just get
blasted by three liters of calm
bro that account now we have to shout
out that account
these are the funniest dudes on earth
man hold on
hold on what is it oh let me find
these boys [ __ ] kids p-h-u-c-k-i-n-g
kids let me let me pull up
one of my favorite ones dog
i'm looking yell this
this one look throw this [ __ ] on the
screen
if you're listening on audio pause and
you gotta come to this right now because
this is
the funniest thing i don't know how we
haven't brought this up
this [ __ ] had me screaming man
i don't think this is i just see a
thumbnail i'm already so excited
this is my favorite brand of tick tock
right now
play it
yo bro
yeah but i think dude the first one is
the best
all right okay let me get that one do
you have that one
no if you go to the page
[Music]
[Laughter]
payback time [ __ ] straws man
what was the one that somebody sent
today of the dude spraying
the guy sleeping with water and then
someone throws a metal trash bin
as he gets up it's such a great like
little cherry on top it's like
tongue wait hold up hold on
scroll it's uh it's like he's like lying
down he's like in a lazy boy
hold up it's coming it's coming how is
that right there there there
yo click into this [ __ ] from the top
they started with champagne so like the
second you woke up it probably felt like
normal and then it just
doused them guys if you're still
listening on audio it's like this guy
gets covered
he's sleeping on a couch and they wake
him up by covering him and literally
like
every single condiment and like leaders
and leaders of this [ __ ] it's like
[ __ ] heavy they cover them with chili
like lettuce comes in the game with a
bottle of
sweet baby raisin just like an inch away
from his face and ramen there's a bunch
of ramen too
oh my god man my face hurts my face
how long would it [ __ ] take to clean
that up bro this
that [ __ ] must have stunk
he came out of that looking like a
ghillie suit just like
covered in that [ __ ] man as [ __ ] yeah i
did not know how we're not talking about
[ __ ] kids the last no
the first one we played when the pasta
hits like
he's like bro and then it's just a pasta
going
and that's just it
oh [ __ ] it's so funny what's the trash
can one
i gotta see this trash can uh i don't
know who sent it where
it was in one of my other threads maybe
whatever
i don't know where to find it
you gotta get this out of the screen
because i'm about to laugh like
uncontrollably
you guys you see the mixture on one of
those they're like what do you put in it
it's like glitter
paint pasta noodles
it's like a [ __ ] like [ __ ]
five-year-old
arts and crafts table just in a bucket
with [ __ ]
milk and other [ __ ] man that's the
beautiful thing about comedy man you can
you can try to be as funny as you want
as witty as you want you could
write it you could write jokes for a
year you'll never be as funny as some
that's spraying ketchup on somebody's
sleeve
that's the funniest thing in the world
besides farting
dog i just like can you imagine that
mixture
in a [ __ ] like a gatorade you know
uh the [ __ ] you know the post game
bin that they always dump on a coach
as you imagine hitting a coat this is
pasta sauce ketchup
lettuce he's like what the [ __ ] we won
anyway when should we do this mcdonald's
sprite let's do it in the bonuses
yeah we got some mcdonald's sprite we're
going to order yeah we got post-mate at
mcdonald's sprite to do a little taste
test because i've never had it before
and so i wanted to experience the
spiciness yeah
on live podcast it is like it's not even
like spicy it's just like
i can't wait it's but it's been sitting
in the fridge for an hour do you think
that [ __ ] it up
it might it maybe melted a little bit
we'll see it should still be corrosive
like you should still get an element of
like
show us luke show us one one bimbo tick
tock before we end and then we'll switch
to the bonus yeah a practical effects
artist tick tock
we're gonna watch that in the bonus too
so is a bimbo
these are multiple questions that i have
been getting from millennials
who is the gen z bimbo
a bimbo isn't dumb i mean she kind of is
but
she isn't that dumb she's actually a
radical leftist
who's pro-sex work bro black lives
matter pro-lgbtq
pro-choice and will always be there for
her girls gays and mace
if you're homophobic i'll castrate you
listen
this is an inclusive organization
there's bimbos
i don't do this for the misogynistic
male games
i do it for my gaze and damn my tits
look good
it's about emotional intelligence at the
end of the day and remember
we always step on trump supporters hi
is that a trump supporter ew
who is puppet i get caught up
i get it i'm caught up now we're caught
up
who is the gen z bimbo there you go
answered
answered bimbo meant something different
yeah 20 years ago
bimbo was like i was like pamela
anderson right that was a bimbo
yeah i was like sort of like ditzy and
you know
it was a mean ass word back in the day
yeah [ __ ] bimbo
okay well now we know interesting and we
know what an accountant is now too
reversed yeah [ __ ] yeah i'm gonna feel
i'm gonna feel totally cool scroll
through tick tock today